Please welcome Kate Mara.
(audience cheers and applauds)
It's so nice to see you.
It's so nice to see you, too, and I can't help it.
I wanna dive right in.
I watched "A Teacher," and I binged it.
The amount of tension I felt in my body watching you
in this character, and it is so brave
to your outward, your inwards.
There's a tenseness, but you make people feel everything
that you're feeling, and that is so hard to do!
And you're doing it!
That is so incredibly generous,
especially coming from you because I respect you so much
as an actress and a producer.
But I know that it's a very specific kind of show,
and it can be hard to watch.
It is a little hard to watch here and there,
but it's riveting, and when you're trying
to convey what you're feeling on the inside,
that is so hard to get across, and yet you do.
How did you do that?
That's so nice to hear, but I think that a lot
of that is just credit to the writers
and the director, Hannah Fidell.
She was going for a very specific thing,
so I think a lot is unsaid in her work,
and I think with this,
my character Claire's life is internal.
I think that the show, they're very dynamic
in its quiet, quiet moments.
That's what I think.
It's a ride, your performance in this show.
I felt a lot of anxiety. I felt a lot of empathy.
I felt it going off the cliff,
but I was riveted watching it.
I wanted to pull it back. It's really good.
It's so well done, and I know you produced this as well.
Yeah.
It's my first television or I guess streaming thing
that I've ever produced.
I only produced one other thing,
so I'm still very new at the whole producing aspect
of my career, but it's been so rewarding
to be a part of this from the very beginning, years ago,
and to be able to be so creatively involved
in every aspect of it.
Now family. You are married to Jamie Bell.
Yes, who loves you so much. (laughs)
I love him so much.
I think he is so talented from "Billy Elliott"
all the way through, and I know what it's like to grow up
in this wonderful job of ours, and he's done it so well.
By the way, you're an animal lover.
Will you please tell me about Chancey?
Aw, you're talking about Chancey the chimp. Look at that.
I had the absolute privilege of being able
to go to Liberia, me and my sister, actually.
We work with this incredible sanctuary.
There he is laughing.
Our friends run a sanctuary there,
and it's me and my sister's passion project
to help get the word out about them.
Liberia Chimpanzee Rescue Protection; they're amazing.
You should follow them on Instagram,
but they're giving homes to all these baby chimps.
I would love to post about it and have it on our website.
We'd love to shine a light on that organization.
Thank you so much for coming on the show.
I am cheering you on.
"A Teacher" on FX on Hulu.
(bright uplifting music)